ma nous les arbres d'esprit ce décor de
man ou multicolores ancestrale coutume
étrange costume chis mystère boutures
grains de vie fleuve épissures lehman ou
flotte s'accroche au vent d'un fils
couvre des tofs ligne
salut je m'appelle seaman cela s'écrit
avec un f
je viens d'un quartier que l'on surnomme
125 sur tous les murs tagués rs connu
des gros titres chronique dans la presse
je suis donc là pour vous cela mais ce
que j ai vécu dans ma jeunesse tout
petit dans ma tête j'avais déjà conçu
une forteresse carcelle je faisais face
à la réputation du quartier de sa
détresse
rien qu'à balader au parc du quartier la
nuit engendrer beaucoup trop de stress
obligé de me rendre à la messe face à la
téloche
un truc qui balancent des trucs moches
de droite à gauche que de la violence à
la sauce us
ça m'a poussé tout petit petit à petit
au mauvais d'elle ce mauvais des liens
lesquels voler dans les villas et les
caisses c'est là que mon frère m'a
présenté la danse qui m'est apparu comme
une déesse et qui m'a sauvé de cet enfer
dans le chef c'est à des ce jeu prend
enfin conscience à quel point il a fait
preuve de beaucoup de sagesse à l'époque
où il m'a mis en pièces
c'était là là là là là l'année où les
bleus ont effectué leurs prouesses dont
98 g 10 ans j'entre dans l'un des
premiers groupes de danse rit prop du
pays qui s'appelle llanes 2008 10 ans a
dansé au même quartier à la même adresse
2012 je crois qu'on a raté la fin du
monde avec justesse pour moi ce n'était
que des foutaises 2016 je n'ai plus la
même adresse mon corps mon âme et mon
cortex ont compris un petit message
quand même je vous le laisse
la valeur de ta vie là est la vraie
richesse qui se comptent pas en dollars
euros ou petites pièces petit frère
futur grand frère petite soeur future
princesse écoute mon cela me remplit de
tristesse la même de tristesse s'est
transformé en allégresse grâce à un art
que tout le monde pense faire du fitness
pour perdre de la graisse mais moi je
sais que sont vos plus je peux t'on
faire la promesse
voulait
est ce qui vient de se passer en
français on dirait que si man vient de
faire un geste
on l'y faut un tout petit peu plus
profond que ça dans ma langue
on dirait trois mecs je vous explique
roy veut dire bush
mais que veut dire yeux en somme c'est
la définition du visage dès que nous
rencontrer nous rencontrons un nouveau
visage une personne ont fait ce geste en
guise de respect et je voulais commencer
par ses gestes avec vous ce soir car
c'est la base de ma conférence gestes
figurent et construction je m'appelle
will sm ludovic seaman ludovic en
français si manon les faux simone qui se
traduit de façon si de ici guère man de
manas 6 bénédiction car je suis un
guerrier béni est mon combat se passe
ici en nouvelle calédonie
où souffle des alizés
ils calédonienne tu égrène les ans aux
versements des flots frissonne des
locaux du percement des hommes ici
sais-tu les choses n'ont pas de prise
les brumes sont exquises et s'estompent
souvent au miroir d'un soleil brûlant
ici vois tu la vague au loin s'élance au
souffle chaud des alizés l'an
balancement des eaux et qu'une des lots
ici sentir le parfum tiare et embaume
les espaces à leur subtilité mais le
vent déjà se lève les ombres marché se
soulèvent chantant en chant mélodieux
comme une rengaine appel joyeux
laisse-moi encore rêver blottie entre
tes bras serrés odeurs ambrée parfum
suave nourrit mois d'été goya au paradis
des secrets sur temps neil nouvelle
calédonie les ans ces graines au
percement des flots sur des îlots
s'égrènent les ans
au percement des mots
mais en tant que guerrier belli j'ai mon
combat et j'ai mes armes
l'art et la culture
pourquoi parce que je suis artiste
danseur hip hop et qu'il ya un petit
souci dans notre pays
notre pays mais se rempli de haine
on va réfléchir ensemble ça fait un pays
et ne réfléchissais tous un tout petit
peu ça fait aussi pays n e
non c'est pas sûr car ici nous et eux on
tape là pis je ne prononce pas le n car
sans la haine c'est beaucoup mieux et
d'un gros mot nous passons un grand mot
un peu plus précieux près des cieux loin
des prétentieux certains pensent pouvoir
lâcher la pression et 20 n'ont d'autres
suivent leur coeur et sa direction foyer
de toutes les émotions pour réfléchir
c'est pas très bon continuons
l'adéquation de pays et nu dans les
plaines on a le mot pie ix
comme certains de nos grands frères mama
pierre bel ou pillot nous montre que la
vie est un chemin sinueux dédicace un
style ouais continuons ce petit jeu pas
très joyeux deux pays et nous on est
passé à pie ix e moi j'aimerais enlever
le e par le web violence est regardé par
la jeunesse avec leurs vies et leurs
actions ne sont plus en adéquation avec
les principes et les préceptes de leur
âge vi e
certains trouvent ça tellement dangereux
que certains de nos jeunes qu'ils
parlent français wallisien ou à dieu
nous disent quelquefois à dieu
continuons ce petit jeu pas très joyeux
de payer nous on enlève la head on
enlève le mieux
il nous reste pas la fin de ce jeu la
lettre p car c'est la paix que l'on veut
tu l'écris comme tu veux mais n'oubliez
pas n'oubliez pas que dans la culture
hip hop
il y en a deux des fois plus de pays
pourquoi je vous dis ça ce soir public
grâce à la culture hip hop
ma culture d'adoption j'ai pu me
rapprocher de ma vraie culture la
culture kanak
je me suis rendu compte qu'il ya des
points communs dans ces deux cultures là
et aussi qu'il ya des différences et ça
fait une richesse
je voudrais vous poser une question quel
est votre culture d'adoption
lorsqu'une culture ça produit des fruits
et je peux vous assurer que si vous
partagez ces fruits là ça fait beaucoup
de bien pourquoi j'ai choisi la culture
est là parce que et ton petit en
calédonie j'ai eu un choc culturel
je suis né à lifou j'ai grandi jusqu'à
l'âge de 7 ans et je suis jumeaux d'une
personne en situation de handicap
à lifou c'est pas très adapté pour les
personnes en situation de handicap
on a dû se déplacer à nous bien est
arrivé là je suis un jeune de lifou je
parle que l'ifo mon prof parle français
seaman regarde moi dans les yeux non
regarde moi dans les yeux baissés les
yeux regarde mon horizon mais ce les eu
chaud culturelles et en tant que dernier
béni ici je voudrais aider toutes les
ethnies qui se cherche et qui essaye de
trouver leur place qu'elle soit là ici
ou à nouméa avec la culture et là je
vais finir ma conférence avec une
anecdote qui m'est arrivé en indonésie
en plein milieu de gamme lan géant gamme
lane ce sont des xylophone tout le son
résonne en moi et ça m'a rappelé ce que
je vivais à lifou j'habite à cinq mètres
d'une église avec une grosse cloche ding
dong
et ça m'a rappelé à plusieurs kilomètres
les choses qui me font deux mois au fond
de moi car je suis de ma famille je suis
de mon peuple je suis d'une communauté
de destin
mais comment suis-je si tout cela éclate
a écrit un jour edgar morin ayant tous
tous des gars pour ce refrain par l'umih
comme l'humain ont un point commun tire
son origine du sol et ne font qu'un au
contact des pâquerettes et du x 1 sans
racines s'enrichissent avec son chéri
sans leurs liens accompagné d'un regard
omniscient est normal vu en venant de
tous nos anciens par et quelquefois en
totem lézard requins cela dépend du pays
du lieu où du recoin nous enseigne qu'il
ya un an semble respectée aussi beau et
fragile que du lin l'humanité se
rapprocher d'elle même et de chacun que
l'on soit des grands vieux ou des tout
petits gamins pour tendre vers la
sagesse ti viens viens viens viens déçu
que certains questions trop souvent pour
connaître leurs lendemains capricorne
poisson je m'en balance je n'en sais
rien tout ce que je sais c'est que
l'être humain
wierre d'aujourd'hui pour demain à
trouver des réponses dans plusieurs
petits chemins
inspiré du sol des cieux et surtout
surtout de leur quotidien
le premier qui me vient ben moi c'est la
danse un art corporel intellectuelle
mais aussi le maquillage ils les ont
ponctué le temps pour lui que pour elle
tatouage marque d'un savoir intemporel
c'est vrai pourquoi pourquoi pourquoi
en gros écrit en gras sentir son
identité et l'atteignant que l'on
s'habille pau souhaite amoco c'est vrai
l'habit ne fait pas le moine mais du
moins sa vigne à l'origine on savait
d'image se sublimer s'imagine quand on
s'abîme avec l'âge
en tout temps à tout âge auparavant
c'était tatouages permanents maintenance
et maquillage pour un petit moment
en gros écrit en gras sentir son
identité et l'atteignant que l'on
s'habille vos souhaits ta moko l'être
humain d'hier d'aujourd'hui pour demain
ont trouvé des réponses dont plusieurs
petits chemins tient une phrase ne viens
viens viens tout ce qui monte fini par
retomber en vain mais l'homme de culture
qu importe sa couleur automne sur ses
racines et encensent pour la culture à
travers le temps les civilisations
ce n'est que le début et non la fin